joe biden besetzt mit dieser rede eine
funktion dieser vier ja nicht besetzt
ist
die des präsidenten aller amerikaner in
der öffentlichen meinung der usa er
versucht das jedenfalls und die frage
ist ob ihm dann wirklich die zustimmung
hier auch seien von den tramp bildern
gegeben wird das wird so lange schwierig
sein solange dort trump daran festhält
ebenfalls das präsidentenamt zu
reklamieren und das kann eben noch eine
ganze zeit sein weil es eben in einigen
bundesstaaten von gesetzeswegen schlicht
nach zählungen also nochmal auszählungen
geben wird genau und das ist auch die
spannendste frage jeder fragt sich
wirklich wie lange werden diese
auszählungen noch gehen sie haben es
gerade gesagt es könnte zu zweiter
auszählungen kommen und zwar dann wenn
der abstand zwischen beiden und trump
unter 0,5 prozent liegt wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn was sagen
sie also wir können jetzt schon sagen
dass zwei staaten definitiv noch mal
auszählen werden
das ist in wisconsin der fall da ist der
abstand zwar jetzt will man nach dem 07
den soweit liegt trump hinten und er
darf wenn er
der abstand ist sozusagen ein prozent
ist dann darf er sie verlangen und das
hat das tram team schon gemacht in
georgia da ist der unterschied 0,1
prozent da muss von gesetzes wegen
ausgezählt werden und den pennsylvania
ist es so dass der abstand 0,4 prozent
der zeit ist auch da müsste von
gesetzeswegen noch mal neu ausgezählt
werden
jetzt muss man abwarten wie der abstand
dann ist denn pennsylvania
wenn dort durch alle stimmen gewertet
wurden aber es gibt auch eine reihe von
staaten wo man auszählen lassen darf
wenn der abstand größer ist das ist im
föderalen system der usa so dass eben
auch jeder bundesstaat seiner eigenen
bestimmungen darüber hat dass man doch
mal eine ausstellung verlangen kann ist
allerdings eine richtig teure
angelegenheit das muss man dazu sagen
für wie es konzern etwa werden über
einen daumen 3 millionen veranschlagt
die das kostet und die muss dann dann
trump aufbringen ja also es bleibt
wirklich brennt man kann es nicht anders
sagen spannend unkompliziert
kommen wir zu den fans von joe biden die
sind sich schon sehr sicher die feiern
schon richtig freuen sich was sagen sie
sind die damen bisschen zu früh dran
oder dürfen die die dürfen dann
sicherlich ne aber bisschen verhalten
würde ich sagen denn das ganze ist eben
noch nicht wirklich über die ziellinie
es ist zwar unwahrscheinlich dass die
nachzählung was anderes ergeben
gewöhnlich werden paar hundert stimmen
gefunden die falsch gewertet wurden das
ist aber bei der vielzahl der stimmen
nichts besonderes aber es könnte eben
auch sein dass diese nachzählung noch
mal begleitet hat von juristischen
scharmützeln dann könnte sich das ganze
hinziehen bis in den dezember wenn die
wahlmänner am 8
dezember feststehen müssen vielleicht
stehen sie dann nicht fest da sind alle
so strategisch taktische überlegungen
die sich das trump team ja schon die
ganze zeit gemacht hat die haben die
ganze zeit darüber nachgedacht wie
können wir an der macht bleiben wenn wir
sie nicht auf ordentlichen weg durch
wahlen gewinnen können und das ist eine
strategie die andere ist und da auch das
spiel pennsylvania eine große rolle dass
man juristisch dagegen vorgehen will das
briefwahl stimmen die nach laden
sozusagen nach schließung der wahllokale
ein ging überhaupt gewertet werden
dürfen
der supreme court hat dass sich daher
nicht er hat sich damit befasst ist zu
keinem urteil gekommen weil so viel zu
vier standen jetzt ist aber mit
richterin bereits die neunte am tisch
das heißt 44 geht nicht wehren und dann
wäre jetzt möglich
das könnte zugunsten von sam und den
republikanern ausfallen
also es gibt ein paar wege ein paar
verschlungene wege wenn ich mal sagen
die trump noch ins weiße haus im weißen
haus halten könnten ich halte sie nicht
ganz für wahrscheinlich aber ich glaube
er wird jeden versuchen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren